thank you
[Music]
welcome back to an interesting episode
of careful boys where today we have
geoquan yeah
I I would like to settle this thing
because let's settle the score guys
because we we mentioned something a
while back and we got a really weird
response and now I'm seeing content
everywhere where it kind of addresses
the same thing and I don't think we
necessarily agree with it so um here it
is
why do some people believe that dating
outside of your race or having
preferences outside of your race counts
as self-hating internalizers are we in
1932 what the [__]
the thing around where like someone who
says like oh you know I like Puerto
Ricans like why do you hate yourself why
do you hate Chinese people well that's
already going in with the assumption
that you're specifically seeking out
another race yeah it's because
they're cherry picking because they do
exist like these people do exist right
like there are people that have some
kind of trauma with their you know same
with gender then no with their own
ethnicity so like girls that might grow
up with the abusive father or whatever
and then they they have this weird
trigger when it comes to let's say Asian
girls that grew up with you know bad
Asian men around them right so they have
this trigger with whenever they see
Asian men and then so then they go oh I
only like black guys or I only like
white guys or whatever and also I seen
this same case in uh like either
adoptees or someone that grew up in an
all-white neighborhood or something like
that where they're so accustomed to
seeing like the popular kid the hot guy
is this one One race whatever and then
they just have a taste for that and they
can't see themselves doing other [__]
the inverse happens where you don't
you're let's say you're just amongst
nothing but like white people right and
then now you're out of your race and now
you travel the world and you're an Asian
you're like [__] Asians are Doper I
don't know but I'm talking about the
people specifically who are looking at
the negative aspects of what exists and
how they create this bias so it may
create this bias because of these
examples of self-hate which it does it
does happen but then the blanket
statement that they create where every
interracial mixed couple is self-hate
that's ridiculous you're talking about
[__] maybe billions of people yeah
that's racist right because I'm also
thinking like okay let's say it is self
hey who cares like why like yeah how
does it affect you the people that that
judge and they go oh this is [__]
self-hate that's right
I actually think because they want the
[__] themselves but they can't get it
that's the thing that I think that's the
that's the biggest reason they're like
she should be with me because if you
hear a lot of the the Asian guys that
think like this they're claiming the
women as if that's they're the entitled
to them like oh they're taking our girls
right so in their head it's like That
was supposed to be my potential mate
that you took away from me right so then
the psychology behind it was like a
projection it is it is it's like why
does he get to have my woman and that's
their explanation to to make sense of
the situation too I think I think they
just go there
but when guys are like you know what
like there are actual girls that
harmfully will say I only date white
guys as a method of like feeling like
that makes them better that's also true
that's true that is true deny that that
exists that exists all the time yeah I
think when a guy responds to even that
by saying like oh you just hate your own
race a lot I also think there's parts of
that where both of them are weird
they should get married
yeah there is that too because I always
I thought it was really weird that uh
when certain like even when I was saying
like oh yeah when I date a Filipino girl
I felt odd uncomfortable feelings of a
pattern final thing yeah like that I
felt that way growing up like familial
like it felt like I was like uh too
close to home a little bit yeah but then
dating your sister but then people were
like for me really yeah what but you
know what but you know what Iran was
dating his cousins that's different yeah
I was doing that yeah but then
but I figured it out what what made me
feel that did you really forget we're
not [__] moving I did but then no
that's a that's a that's a difference my
first cousin second cousin no it was not
like that it was just a not like
subscribe to the channel
but I realized why I developed that
feeling why and it's this very specific
thing so this is my history of
ex-girlfriends it goes Filipino Filipino
Korean Filipino Chinese Chinese Filipino
white white white white white okay and
the reason for that is because you have
ten girls
that's 25 years of dating and then my
current I don't know my current girl now
is like eight of those years but up
until then I was just an idiot I don't
think it's cool that you date a lot of
people that's dumb but there's nothing
wrong with dating a lot of people what
happened to me is that what I realized
through dating
Filipino people is that
um
I I am not the Orthodox dream of a
Filipino parent that their daughter is
dating me like I'm not the first pick I
have a weird [__] life I'm not I
wasn't getting good grades he's not a
nurse not the traditional exactly so you
know my my thing that I dealt with a lot
of the time either dancing or play
basketball or something but they want
the medical thing they don't want that
yeah they want to x-ray Filipino they
want a [__] pharmacist Filipino they
want a nurse Filipino so what I dealt
with even when I was dating you know
Chinese girls or Korean like what
happened to me every time in those early
years was I would have to feel like I'm
doing parental approval all over again
because your own parents already yeah
dealing with that in my own family and I
already coped with it I already said all
right I'm the black sheep I suck ass I'm
I'm okay with that yeah and then I go to
my you know Partners family and they
feel the same way about me oh that's and
it's hard it's like oh [__] like I have
to like and and they're even more
predisposed to not like me because they
have to protect their daughter yeah and
I can understand that and then later on
as I started dating outside of Asians I
found that when I dated and and these
aren't just like California white uh
Partners I had it was it was Nashville
white Tampa white uh Denver Tampa white
is this Swedish white and now Australian
white and every one of those things
the the parental feelings were more like
they wanted me to feel good about myself
that's more open and I really understood
that like in my particular situation
where there are qualities about me that
I appreciate and I enjoy about myself
and they'll they'll never be appreciated
by certain uh parents and that's totally
understandable but I won't ever be able
to impress them enough because I don't
feel confident in myself with them and
and I want them to get the the dream son
in law that they want yeah so it never
worked out for me dating Asians for that
reason specifically and I think because
of my unique experience I took with me
an odd trauma and like an odd Taste of
like oh God dating a Filipino girl makes
me feel like I have to fight this battle
all over again yeah dating Asians to me
felt like dating outside of my race
because I'm Japanese yeah like in
America everything is like Asian is it's
like you're grouped up into one group
but we're not the [__] same dude like
Anthony has the best [__] reactions
yeah
I mean Japanese is Asian right but then
the the when you're in Asia they don't
[__] see it that way they're like I'm
[__] Chinese what are you talking
about like that we're so different like
it's it's a different world completely a
different world so then like I never
even saw it as like I'm dating my own
kind but how do you respond to someone
that's calling you
self-hating internalized racist
because you're dating Hannah like that's
your problem yeah it sounds like a
person or because you're with because
you're with them I think where they are
so stupid and inexperienced is it's hard
enough to keep any relationship period
it's hard enough to have someone love
you and want to be with you and stay
with you
you just gotta hope that the person that
you're with will tolerate your [__] and
stay with you as long as possible so
most people that are making these claims
they're in Loveless worlds like they
don't know what it's like to try to hold
on to something I think that's the
explanation though the guys that's the
people that say that about like oh you
hate this race or you're not gonna date
this race because you're self-hating I
think it's a over simplification I think
the more likely answers that they have
racist too right it's so racist it's
like okay yeah that could be a potential
but more likely it's what Joe's saying
it's like that's hard to be in a
relationship
perspective is so surface that they
think that that's the only like
determining factor that a couple stays
together yeah and all it's a big it can
be a big talk like it can be a big part
of a relationship and I think before
people think of like oh when you date
outside your race it is a big deal
especially in Asian communities but I
don't know and like to your point Joe
where you're saying that just to be in a
relationship in general is really
difficult because you're bringing two
separate people that have separate
worlds now combining these separate
worlds and kind of combing through all
that and then when you're dating outside
of your race there's this other added
layer of like you're not dating someone
that grew up in a sort of similar
cultural background yeah why would you
want to make it harder on yourself
you're not trying to make it really it
does add another layer of complexity now
that like there's two cultures kind of
coming together
so yeah I don't think people want to
make it harder for themselves on purpose
but we're all an interracial mixed
except that guy but I would
considered according to him us Asians
are not the same it's not the same you
are I think the only thing that brings
Asians together is the ground Foundation
of um Confucianism that's it there's
that's we have a hierarchy and vital
like [__] piety [__] where it's like
uh your your government parents all that
like the structure is the same so you
bring a bunch of Asians together then
you can like assemble and work yeah I
also think it's like a highly
um I think the more you get into
relationships and understand how people
work in society it becomes a highly
individualistic and I think people that
have those blanket statements they're
still stuck in that phase where they
just see like all zebras are zebras you
know what I mean like when you have when
you go to like a dog breeder if I'm not
in a [__] golden retriever world yeah
they all look like golden retrievers but
they can tell oh yeah like Sammy likes
to [__] chews on her foot [__]
Timmy likes to [__] on the floor yeah
like and like they look at Alex Asians
retrievers and they can tell all the
individualistic things about each other
because that's what they're looking at
they're not looking at the surface like
looks and skin color or whatever right
you got [__] you know like also I
like to think that like let's say um
you go to a like Japan or China or any
of these they're predominantly one
ethnic group One race so it's like you
come to a place like America that's like
a Melting Pot of a lot of different
people you're gonna have people that
marry different people it happens you
gotta get a mixed bag and it's not good
or bad or it doesn't make you better
it's just you [__] fell in love with
this guy yeah yeah yeah I also have
preferences
I I also don't like that statement of
like your own kind because if we're an
American our own kind is like he's
American yeah I have way more
similarities with like you went outside
what am I doing I have more similarities
with like let's say my the Mexican kids
in my neighborhood that I grew up than
Japanese kids in Japan I can see that so
I'm like sure why do Asians and other
people believe that their their old
country because it's Ray racist I don't
[__] know man like we're Americans
and like it's a very unique experience I
also don't think some of these people
have dated enough I don't know that's
true dated at all it's honestly like
that's my I think if you date enough
diverse people you just figure out like
it's just [__] love dude does it have
sticking to the rule duh and they're
right we all [__] up I do think though
from my experience there's way more of a
connection through class and maybe time
of like
shared memories of time era so like
let's say you're Millennial with
Millennial right and then you have
shared memory of Ninja Turtles or
something like that or some phenomenon
like Saved by the Bell in a western
Nation a lot of us watch the same shows
right and also like class like if you're
rich and you all had Maids you know what
that's like you know what it's like to
have a servant
they're gonna connect like a rich
Indonesian is going to connect with the
rich British more than you know like
maybe a poor Indonesian and a rich
Indonesian so like maybe the same Foods
you might eat but I've had way more of a
connection with class than race yeah
yeah all right and that's the same thing
with me it's like in some relationships
I feel like Aladdin and others I feel
like Prince Ali
foreign
either way I'm Indian
you should be Aladdin for Halloween one
year dude just to see what happens but
then it's true like because a lot of
these videos are probably neck shark
thanks oh gosh thank you for being as a
service a lot of these like videos are
like guys that are like angry at Asian
girls for saying that they're they only
date whites but it's like they're you're
losing it it's also like also that
statement though of someone saying I
only date this thing it's also [__]
weird it is super weird [__] weird
I'd rather say like I only date
um people with good morals or like
people that like I don't know I'd rather
go with big butts Hobbies or some [__]
then like I only date this like it's
weird but if somebody really does look
at that like that makes them Elite like
I only date white people like let them
have that [__] delusion yeah like why
does that affect you yeah we don't have
a shortage of Purity
because she could be dating like
kind of white and then she thinks she's
prestigious because she's like I'm with
a white person and we're just like nope
you're with Cletus dude
Cletus
yeah but that is The Stereotype those
like you see some of these like dude
like see dork white guys I go to Asia
and they think they deserve like the
hottest Asian chick yes because they go
away Asian girls love us you know like
yeah but that's an ecosystem in itself
it shouldn't affect you it shouldn't
make you angry statistically they do
have larger penises so I mean I get it
sometimes Anthony what team are you on
brother oh dude Bieber you want bro I
thought the video's over dude you just
admitted you have a little dick no I
have an average one white guys just have
big dick
dude you sounds like you want to marry a
white guy on average like you are I'm
just jealous yeah you're six foot shut
up I'm 5 12. this is probably big too
basically the point is if you [__]
fall in love with someone outside your
race don't feel bad about that [__]
don't let someone else make you feel bad
about that it's fine oh yeah that's our
stance but also yeah who yeah like if
they do have internalized racism right
like
what's the outrage toward I feel bad I
don't know I guess I actually feel
I don't know like when I see someone
like that that hate themselves maybe
their culture or they're embarrassed of
it because maybe they grew up in a
neighborhood where the kids around them
made them feel less than right so then
they they develop this internal like to
me that makes me feel sorry for them not
hate them yeah like I don't get angry at
the girl for thinking she's Superior
because she's dating only white guys or
whatever I feel like damn how much how
must that feel you look at yourself in
the mirror you [__] hate your [__]
ass eyes you [__] you know what I
mean like you're like I wish I was white
you know and you [__] bleach your
hair blonde and [__] and all that that's
different if you wish you were wrong and
then I'm all like that's a different
problem like that's so sad right like
that's a mental disability each their
own issues you know what I'm saying true
everybody's different and it's not to
say that we're all supposed to agree
like unilaterally everybody has to have
the exact same idealisms and live by the
same principles but I don't love that I
don't feel angry at her I went sideways
okay
I think I think
also like how does that affect me and my
ability to get women like if she doesn't
that's the bigger problem yeah I'm
thinking about really cares and do you
even want her is she attractive to you
in the first place shouldn't it just be
her loss then
that's how it should be seen
yeah but that's why I think you're right
when you say some guys have an animosity
because they feel like they're entitled
to this person's taste or they use it
what's preventing you from dating
outside like do you only prefer Asian
women and you want pure Asian like
Superior race children so like is that
what you're trying to do is keep you
know like I don't get it like yeah it
seems weird you don't get her but what
about all the other available women out
there that are single lots of ways to
you know what there's lots of ways to
enrich your own Community without
putting your sperm in all of them
you don't have to [__] I love how that
was a message for the camera like you
guys need to understand I do want to
talk to these guys with these positions
though and and I I actually want to know
what their I think a lot of it too is
like an excuse it's easier to say that
because it's like a bigger problem than
you and it kind of takes your own
responsibility out of the situation of
like oh I can't change yourself and
develop it kind of yeah because that's
person you want to be for the perfect
wife or husband like there has to be an
aspect of you
to change yourself or to better yourself
or progress yourself I think people
don't I think it's harder to not do that
you know but also I think people need to
mind their own [__] business you know
yeah that's it yeah mind their own
[__] business stop worrying about
who's dating who
[__] hey
yeah whoa my sticker man bro you better
watch out that's okay
I wonder bring that up there's like
Asian guys out there in like the Midwest
in all white neighborhood and then like
these three Asian girls that he went up
to were like ew well Asian guys only
date white guys and then he's like man
[__] this [__] dude I didn't even do
anything wrong right and I'm wondering
like if I'm just in LA and I don't know
these guys lives that's true and that
they built this animosity because I
think that's fair because that might I
could imagine that [__] because I'm in
La dude and like also it's different
right like
we can actually get really give a [__]
about stuff well I I also I also would
like if someone said that to you you
probably wouldn't care I would also
Imagine a similar scenario let's say as
an Asian dude who like grew up in an
all-white like neighborhood and like
let's say I went to high school right
and then some white chick starts dating
this Asian dude because he's the one
Asian dude there and then other white
homies are like dude that's messed up
you got to be dating your own kind we
would look at that be like that's some
pure area and race [__] yeah so if it's
going the other way and Asians are
complaining about girls dating white
dudes isn't that some pure Aryan race
type like mentality yeah brother raise
that hand up again I've heard the
argument of people saying that white
people don't say that about other white
people where they go oh dating him is
like dating my brother
I've heard it from a white girl yeah I
heard that too yeah well I know a couple
whites that say the same thing they
don't date other whites because it makes
them feel like home where they were from
in Tampa and like they're just like I I
just don't I feel like their experience
is so similar to mine yeah I want to
date people with different experiences
and different cultures people gravitate
to the universe and and usually white
people it is their sibling and they're
with them and then they're just like it
is kind of like dating my brother but he
is my brother so it's okay
but it's also funny that within just
whites as a whole there's way more
diversity than you know Filipino
Americans yeah it's like this guy could
be polish or [__] something else like
that's pretty white to me
[Laughter]
I don't know man this is a weird why are
we going backwards dude like yeah it's a
weird thing we got some real Elementary
Minds speaking out like I think these
dudes are just mad at a very specific
type of girl yeah and it's and it's
getting kind of bled over to just
everyone in interrelation interracial
relations they're mad at themselves
they're really just mad at them they're
empowered by the [__] keyboard yeah
that's another thing oh they're simple
but these but these kind of thoughts
still existed decades I remember when we
were coming up in like people still
thought this way I think people have
always been mad at themselves even like
the Stick it to the Man or people
getting mad at [__] billionaires it's
just people have their own problems and
it's just way easier to blame something
else than to change yourself change your
life man [__] you on that [__]
billionaire it's way more comforting you
just feel better if I stopped using
Amazon then you're like I love Amazon
just [__] Bezos
these people also just really do not
want you to think you're better than
them yeah but no what I like about that
statement is that they think you're even
thinking about them in the
I ain't thinking about you I'm trying to
[__] survive on my own right here I'm
trying not to [__] up my own
relationship making videos about you
that's all we're not thinking about you
if you're we're just directly addressing
you if you're a guy yeah you don't
you're you're sexless you're Loveless
you don't have any of that going for you
that's your [__] fault like I think
that's it so you're talking right at me
it's up to you talking to Nick you're
looking right at me dude
seriously like if you
you're not entitled to it you have to
earn love you have to earn I'm trying
you have to earn it like that has to be
yeah it's like you you might think you
don't have options you could be bitter
so how do I earn love though
you got to be Rico Suave